there is a uh viral video
it's i guess it's a comedy video
not you're not you know it's not uh
exactly dangerfield but but it's oh
it's i guess it's supposed to be comedy
about how we
should just do whatever fauci tells us
to do
i've just had my third shot
a booster they call it
how many more are they going to make us
get
don't know don't care because i like you
probably understand there is a global
pandemic and people much much smarter
than you and me have decided this is the
best plan of action to avoid lots more
people dying or cluttering up hospital
hallways you and i we're doing our part
by getting one more little prick
and not being one
and not being one so just do whatever
fauci says even though fauci has
contradicted himself at least half a
dozen times during this epidemic just
whatever he says at this moment
do that because these are people who are
much smarter than you and me listen
buddy
i'm not
disputing the fact that these people are
much smarter than you
but just because they're smarter than
you does not mean they're smarter than
me
and it doesn't mean that they're smarter
than the rest of us
i don't think that our ruling class is
smarter
than
a lot of americans i don't think that dr
fauci is smarter
he's certainly not wiser
than
the great many americans who oppose him
i don't think whatever little he knows
about some scientific field he doesn't
seem to know jack diddley about
philosophy
morality
political philosophy our system of
government or much of anything else for
that matter and these these questions
really uh should weigh into our decision
on how how we react to his edicts
i'm glad you like that clip
it was one of my favorite clips it was
so i'm glad that you liked i'm glad we
have similar tastes
you got to ring the bell subscribe and
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]